- So also, why you're an amazing human
is I recently heard that
you love journaling.
I'm a huge journal kid.
- Yeah?
- No I get a little nervous
about someone finding it, but uh
(chuckling)
- [Leslie] I know.
- Cause that's happened to me before,
someone found it and like read it.
And then accused me of what was in it.
And I was like, that's my mess.
I was like, wait, what?
(audience laughing)
I was like, you jumped in that tornado.
That's on you.
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
But like, I love it though,
it makes me feel good
to get it out.
- Yeah, it kinda, it's
a yeah, another thing
that's changing a lot,
will change your life.
I started waking up an hour
and a half to two hours
before my wife and my kids.
- I wanna do that.
So you have you time.
- It's my me time, you know, journal.
I do my yoga.
I drink my coffee and stuff.
And it's a chance for me
to find out where I am
before the day starts rushing in.
And you know, I've had realizations.
For the record, you know,
I went through one of those
really tough seasons that's
kinda waiting for everybody.
If you haven't been
through it yet, just wait,
it's coming, you know.
- Yeah.
- But you know, one of those seasons
and I journal through the whole thing.
And I really was just
honestly trying to make it
to the other side of that.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- And I never was thinking
that I would use it creatively in any way.
But it dawned on me this one day
as I was listening to music.
And music was such a balm
and such a guiding light--
- Oh yeah.
- [Leslie] Through that time.
- It's healing.
- It was like, I'm supposed to use this.
I'm supposed to write about this.
If I'm supposed to make the record
that I needed to listen to
when I'm going through this.
- You mind if I tag into
the journaling conversation
you were having.
- [Kelly] Yes, do you journal?
- I do.
I say this and especially,
you just played a clip from.
But I find if you write
down every few nights
what you're saddest
about or angriest about,
you can start to see
your own life as a story.
And when you see your own life as a story,
sometimes you can zoom out and
encourage the main character
to make better decisions.
- Wow.